[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live on the podcast
walls of david.net
and who is this fine gentleman that we
have in the realm today oh hi i'm jim
rhymes with mayhem executive director of
counterintelligence operations at
devolver digital entertainment a
subsidiary of fort parker so legal happy
fun time cayman island offshore holdings
hashtag crimes he got bars he got balls
he's ready so long this is one of the
most highly anticipated titles trick to
yomi that samurai action we got lord
addict on the gameplay right now so
let's get right into it right now first
thing off the bat you're seeing this
beautiful beautiful
almost
japanese seminar game yeah absolutely
inspired by
old samurai movies you know curious
stuff like that uh black and white you
got the film grain on the screen
um and it's i mean it's a very cinematic
dramatic experience right coupled with
uh you know action action now the thing
that we're noticing right now that i
like is that you almost have this size
going and almost
you could potentially go into the
foreground sure
so it plays i mean it's um primarily a
side stroller experience but like like a
lot of games you can move into the
foreign background here and there so
like right now it's you know it's left
to right but now we're moving at an
angle
just to get different angles uh you know
point of view camera shots and stuff
just to get that cinematic experience
absolutely love it man because it really
takes you into different angles
different positions different viewpoints
yeah and i'm loving the body that just
floated by but we're going to be able
right yeah yeah no i it took me a while
to notice that i was very excited when i
first saw it absolutely now as far as
the gameplay system you know
basic attack carry yep let's go what's
the basics of the game play the sword
player you've got a you've got a light
attack and with your left stick you can
like if you hold up you'll do an upward
slash down downward slash forward you'll
do a thrust
with your light attack
so yeah you can go up into these some of
these houses he said you go to the house
so this is a little bit 3d i love that
and you got very like dramatic harsh
lighting
shadows
uh reminiscent of those old films this
is really cool now
if you do certain things like save
villages does it change anything
sorry about saving villagers
because i noticed like
uh well the protagonist of the game is a
little more um morally outstanding than
that not what i'm playing not when
you're playing
the good news is sometimes when you do
go in so what you did when you rescue
those villagers i don't know if you saw
in the upper left corner you did unlock
a new move so if you hold b to sprint
and then hit your y for heavy attack
you'll do uh like a forward thrust like
a stagger attack and you see that uh
leading into it so when you're not in
combat you can't really do okay combat
moves but go down up that ladder and
you'll find somebody to fight nice
so technically this is a non-combat
section until we get yeah when you draw
this sword that's when you're ready so
we hold down b and then the y yeah you
run forward so b is your your so you've
got a roll which is not like a it's not
like an iframes dodge roll it's just
about moving through space so you can
still yeah
so yeah you can do cherries
he's doing primarily there we go there
you go
let's go
i just love the switching from backside
this this is my favorite camera sorry i
didn't know the camera angle right here
where we're inside a building looking
through the window
pushing through as he runs up there yeah
sorry don't know that i just took me
somewhere you took me somewhere i was
waiting for that shot
no you took me somewhere it's beautiful
and again
the thing what i was going to say as far
as move sets yeah are there going to be
more additional media sets of things you
can learn
in traxxas you can there's a few combos
you can learn you know so like you know
when he rescued those villagers he
unlocked that new move so there are
things you can do to unlock new moves
like villagers you can get some moves
sometime
he didn't notice because he was busy
fighting but that boat again slowly
through the frame with bodies riddled
with arrows just
a lot of really nice environmental
storytelling going on so from a
storytelling standpoint you know what
what is the basic premise for those who
don't know anything about succulents is
it a person who lost his family his
child oh
there are shrines throughout the world
sorry in in the real game you get a
tutorial explaining these things uh
there will be these shrines that you
need to touch and they serve as
checkpoints i mean he wrecked his way
through here the first time so i'm sure
he won't get impatient and murdered on
his way back right so quick question
i've noticed that
they absolutely can and sometimes if
you've got like so you're tearing
through these guys but if you let one of
them last a little too long he'll come
around behind you oh so there's a shrine
go ahead and grab that that'll restore
your health and so this is a checker
there you go and there's your answer
there yeah
a light attack in a direction you'll do
it and then there's also you can hit a
and they'll just flip
so if you do well you were worn out but
if you do stun somebody like that you
can hit right bumper to do a finisher so
right bumper is the finisher okay i'm
not good enough to consistently stagger
people so i never remember to do that
when it happens i'm just shocked that it
happened
so i was saying like from a basic story
premise like yeah what
it is not a story of a guy who's having
a good
life
yeah i mean i don't want to
because it is such a cinematic
experience because it is such a strong
narrative experience i don't really want
to go into too much about it but
what i like about
yeah yeah are there any kind of boss
encounters there are okay nice they're
all only boss encounters nice um
i don't think we've got i haven't seen
anyone get far enough into this demo to
find out if we've got one in this demo
okay um but there are definitely boston
counters in the game so we got bodied
again but we're gonna go to the
checkpoint
that's a good thing you know what
checkpoints are yeah that's good there's
another one we missed uh right before
that wagon that you pushed on the same
screen is the wagon there's another
check what we're gonna do is when he
gets to that dragon
yeah we're gonna get them checkpoints
because there's a lot of deaths going on
now you take extra damage when your
stamina runs out though by the way and
this leader here is the stamina yeah
right okay god i got it now the stamina
will complete just on any action is it
just like that even parry do we know uh
i don't think it depletes very much on
perry if it does
how does that control feel
back yeah it gives you your health
that's why okay it makes sense i thought
he was just playing hardcore yeah
he's that guy this is the elder ring
soul spot
nice
don't keep moving forward when you're
worn out though
take a break
there we go
okay
right now
on your d-pad real fast
okay so you have little throwing knives
if you hit right no left trigger uh when
you're in combat you'll throw one of
those it does a little damage you got
the kills
okay okay
let's go let's see if we can get a
little farther
all right here it is
nice
gotta get busy now
nice
keep going keep it going
okay okay
getting a little further maybe we can
see a little bit more
and again
i know storylines we're not revealing
but as far as um
um it's not a super long game
like i mean it's uh
once you've learned it once you've
played through it you can probably beat
it in
like maybe four hours i think if i'm not
mistaken
so it's a you know it's a shorter so
this is uh it's made by guys i'm part of
the flying wild hog team nice who make
uh like the shadow warrior game yes so
this is being made in parallel to the
shadow warrior three
so that was their you know their bigger
experience now what if this is just more
yeah no this is that's really cool
because i remember the experience of the
of the dev
the thing that really got our eye we saw
at first initially on the playstation
conference yeah and it looked phenomenal
but one thing we were surprised to see
which i'm very happy is that it's coming
in game packs yeah and the deal with
gamecast and making that come together
so that whole bunch of users that have
access to the server yeah can also play
it and i thought that was interesting
because of the fact that we only said
initially on the playstation side yeah
just trying to open it up to a bigger
audience more people show gamers yeah
and for indy you know for any studios
you know it's really great to have these
these sort of services that you know
guarantee you know make sure that you
know it's going to be some success
absolutely love our independent
developers love to see the game shine
hopefully attic can stop getting killed
at this point i keep forgetting
murdering yeah we got to get there
we'd like to see the end of the stage as
possible
i'd love to find out if there's a boss
yeah i would love i would love to know
if you're the boss too
we given the difficult game conquer
that's his name nickname difficult
slack
there we go
and if you can
oh wow
really good
[Music]